you know Mindy I was thinking about your
schedule don't you dream of a day when
you no longer have the pressure of
having to write the show and like just
pick up a couple of acting Parts where
you don't have all that pressure the the
week must be really long if you're
writing it and starring in it it's a ton
of work but it's also this it is
literally the thing I dreamed about when
I was 5 years old doing so and I'm never
bored I could be overworked but I'm
never bored so when I go to other
people's things that's like not my dream
I kind of care less about them well how
do you write a TV a hit TV show do you
just go home and write a pilot script is
that how you do it I um I thought about
all the things that I wasn't able to do
in my current situation and said what
are the things I want to do what are the
stories that I can't tell when you do
like a mock documentary and then write
that right and so that's kind and you
sat down and wrote it yourself sat down
and wrote it myself wow at that point
I'd written when I left the office in
season 8 to go do my own show I'd
written like 25 episodes of the office
and what do you do after you let's say
you write the pilot who do you give that
to Fox did you go write to Fox or did
you bring it to everybody so I had a
deal with NBC Studios they had me in a
deal at the office where I was like I
was going to write an act in the office
and part of the deal is I would write
this pilot for them okay and I wrote
this pilot um where I'm the lead of the
show I play this OBGYN and I'm super
proud of it and I turned it into NBC
Studios right and NBC decided they took
it to the network to see if they liked
it and NBC passed on my show
yeah and aren't you defeated don't you
say oh if I can only explain it to them
they would understand I it was like one
of the worst days because it was my exit
strategy and I'm by the way like I have
a huge ego and anyone who's worked with
me in the office like I have a lot of
confidence and I think I'm a good writer
and that was sort of I hadn't thought of
it but I was like yeah this is I'm going
to go leave from the office and then I'm
going to go do that show and it was
completely devastating so after NBC
where do you bring it do you bring it to
Fox so Kevin Kevin riy at the time was
the head of fox Kevin riy Kevin riy okay
and he had been the head of NBC when I
got hired on the office right and I
actually met him for the job and he'd
been a real champion of shows that I
liked like he was the one that really
believed in the office and got us a
second season when people really didn't
want there to be a second season and he
championed that he green lit 30 Rock and
then he left NBC to go run Fox and so
the minute that they passed I said let's
take it to Fox cuz you knew Kevin was
there I knew Kevin was there andion my
you know at least I had a nice
relationship with him at that point they
read it that night I set up a meeting
for like the day after whatever and I
went in and met with them and he told me
hey we I like the script I think it's
super funny I want to be in business
with you and he was there with Suzanna
makos who's actually still there and is
one of our Executives and said make
these changes and then come back to us
and that was like the test for me wow
they had some pretty big changes they
wanted to make not with any of the
characters but like some of the story
stuff do you do it or you get resentful
oh I did it in in a in a heart heart
they they were good notes second of all
they weren't notes where it's just like
hey we want you to be the sidekick and
now it's a white girl as the lead you
know what didn't insult me they still
bought into you as the lead they bought
into me as the lead and the tone of it
they liked which as you know tone is so
important they didn't want it to be a
multicam show with a laugh you know they
didn't ask me to do something like
that